The Commonwealth of Fallout 4 is full of desolate
wonder and interesting characters—​who
you can then kill and loot.
It's also home to some locations that wouldn't
be out of place in Freddy Krueger's ambien-fueled
nightmares.
It doesn't matter how decked out your Power
Armor is, because fear can penetrate the hardiest
of suits.
Grab your security blanket, duck under the
covers, and check under the bed for feral
ghouls as we dive into these pulse-raising
locations.
Swan's Pond
While it's not very scary on the surface,
Swan's Pond near Boston Common is terrifying
for another reason.
You might think you're just passing by a pond,
with nothing noteworthy around, but then it
happens: the ground begins to rumble.
You turn around just in time to see the ugly
face of one of the game's Unique Super Mutant
Behemoths named Swan who, incidentally, has
a big plastic swan strapped to his shoulder.
If you don't become a crater within the first
few seconds of encountering him, you might
just be able to take him down to get a legendary
furious power fist weapon.
That is, if you don't crap your pants when
you first encounter him.
Suffolk County Charter School
A school in the middle of a post-apocalyptic
wasteland?
How creepy could it be?
Of course, the answer is "very, very creepy,
indeed."
What makes Suffolk County Charter School unique
is the school's history.
If you look into the background of the school,
you'll find out how it was a part of a government
experiment called the Nutritional Alternative
Paste Program.
That means that the school swapped out its
rubbery chicken nuggets and crappy pizza for
pink sludge.
So, in other words, it was an upgrade.
Still, apparently the paste increased aggression
in the students and actually turned their
skin a little pink.
While that's pretty gross, fans of Fallout
are no strangers to seeing the results of
experiments gone awry.
But there's something more unnerving than
usual to walk into the school and see all
the feral ghouls with bubblegum-pink skin.
Dunwich Borers
Ah, the Dunwich Borers, a place where hope
goes to die and where your sense of reality
goes to get warped.
If you're at all familiar with the works of
H.P.
Lovecraft, then you might have picked up on
the reference to "The Dunwich Horror," a short
story written in 1928.
You might also recognize the name "Dunwich"
because it appeared in Fallout 3 in the form
of the Dunwich Building, a dungeon that featured
a lot of supernatural phenomena and was arguably
the creepiest place in the the Capital Wasteland.
The Dunwich Borers is a dig site that looks
innocent enough...or as innocent as a place
in a Fallout game can get.
But it hides a terrible secret.
As you get clamber deeper into the pit, you'll
witness supernatural flashbacks akin to the
ones from the Dunwich Building and a bunch
of feral ghouls trying to gnaw your face off.
If you venture deeper, you can find a dagger
called Kremvh's Tooth at the bottom of a well.
You'll also see part of a face poking out
of the water, presumably belonging to a statue
of some elder god or some kind of entity worshipped
by the Dunwich company.
Milton Parking Garage
Remember the Saw movies?
Remember how badly you wanted to feel like
you trapped in one of them, but only lacked
the psychotic friends necessary to make your
dreams come true?
Well good news: ​Fallout 4​'s Milton Parking
Garage has got you covered.
Located next to the Milton General Hospital,
the labyrinthine, booby-trapped garage, contains
devices designed to maim you, locked-room
puzzles, and even more mannequins, placed
there with the sole purpose of giving players
the heebie-jeebies.
Creepier than the dungeon itself is the question
that looms after you've escaped: who put this
whole, crazy thing together and why?
And seriously, where's he getting all the
mannequins?
It looks like a J.C. Penney on coupon day.
Museum of Witchcraft
One of the absolute coolest places in all
of the Commonwealth is The Museum of Witchcraft.
And it's one you should probably avoid if
you're not armed to the teeth.
You'll actually be sent here if you pick up
the quest called "The Devil's Due" and decide
to track down some missing soldiers that belong
to the Gunners, but it's still best to wait
until you're really ready to deal some damage.
The front doors are locked tight, so you'll
need to enter the building through the basement.
If you have Stealth Boys, you'll want to use
them, because you'll immediately discover
that you're not alone in the building.
Floorboards creak and inhuman noises fill
the air.
Experienced players will recognize the sound
as everyone's favorite monster: a Deathclaw.
And not only does that Deathclaw stalk you
through the museum's halls, but around every
corner you'll encounter a bunch of spooky
mannequins meant only to raise your blood
pressure even more.
If you manage to avoid or kill the beast,
you can loot a mound of Deathclaw eggs.
And you know what that means: omelettes for
everyone!
Or, more accurately, a whole lot of caps.
Pickman Gallery
This place will really make you wonder whether
or not you should help everyone you meet in
the Commonwealth.
Upon entering the Pickman Gallery, you'll
see a bunch of disturbing paintings hanging
on the wall, all painted with vibrant reds
and yellows.
Heh, kinda like Nintendo Pikmin.
They all show scenes pulled straight out of
depths of hell.
Or maybe just a typical day at Five Guys Burgers
and Fries.
We're not quite sure.
More to the point, you'll see a bunch of raiders
trying to kill a man named Pickman.
Should you choose to save him, he'll drop
some creepy lines of gratitude and give you
a key that lets you loot a safe for a weapon
called Pickman's Blade.
Once you really take a look around and see
all of the buckets of blood and dismembered
body parts everywhere, and then think about
the name of the weapon, it'll dawn on you
that Pickman is a maniac who paints those
freakish paintings using the blood of his
victims.
So that answers that question: those are definitely
pictures of Five Guys.
Or, you know, ground up Nintendo Pikmin.
Either way.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to tell us which Fallout
4 location put you off solid food for the
longest.